Republicans have described a Kazuya
Cortes as the leader of her party as the
boss of the Democratic Party and there's
a reason that they're saying that
because she is and she said so herself
in an interview on Friday watch this
oh it's unrealistic oh it's vague oh it
doesn't address this little minut thing
and I'm like you try you do it cuz
you're not because you're not so until
you do it I'm the boss she is the boss
so how did this happen well for the last
two years Democrats have been very
distracted they have spent all of their
time hating Donald Trump and none of
their time thinking about what they
would do if they ever took charge as he
just did of the Congress last November
so they arrived in Washington in January
and they have no idea what to do
lucky for them someone had a plan she
was a 29 year old bartender from the
Bronx and she wrought showed up with a
brand-new Democratic platform already
written she imposed it on her party it's
called the green New Deal and in less
than two months she has basically
convinced the entire leadership of the
Democratic Party to buy into this plan
to ratify it it's a perfect plan it
would shut down the entire American
economy except for the hedge funds that
fund Democratic campaigns mm-hmm
absolutely perfect there's only one
downside the plan if enacted would cost
some estimate more than the entire
global GDP not the GDP of the United
States but the GDP of the world it's
pretty expensive but it doesn't bother
Acacio cortes at all she doesn't care
listen to her describe her reaction to
the bean-counters description of this is
too expensive here's what she says in
response our planet is going a big
disaster if we don't turn the ship
around and so it's basically like
there's scientific
census that the lives of children are
gonna be very difficult and it does lead
I think young people to have a
legitimate question you know should is
it okay to still have children is it
okay to still have children well I don't
know Alexandria can we hear the boss now
if you say we can't reproduce the
species of course we won't it's your
call oh my gosh it's a measure of how
cowardly and passive everyone's become
all of a sudden then a chorus of
right-thinking Democrats hasn't told
this idiotic windbag to be quiet and
take a seat don't talk until you learn
something but of course nobody's done
that they're all too afraid of her what
you're watching isn't politics it's a
Children's Crusade an army of tiny
combatants marching off an oversized
clothes into an unknown puffed up with
ignorant self-righteousness last week as
if on cue activists showed up with a
group of kids to harass California
Senator Dianne Feinstein for the crime
of not endorsing the ground what's
interesting about this group is I've
been doing this for 30 years I know what
I'm doing you come in here and you say
it has to be my way or the highway I
don't respond to that any plan that
doesn't take full transformative action
is not going to be what we need well you
know better than I do so I think one day
you should run for the Senate mm-hmm you
almost almost feel a little bad for
Dianne Feinstein this is not the
politics that she joins when Dianne
Feinstein became a u.s. senator 27 years
ago the Democratic Party was still sort
of tethered to reality they cared about
the middle class or said they did they
wanted a secure border Dianne Feinstein
made in that case herself they said they
wanted abortion to be legal but
least they said they also wanted it to
be rare they never told you not to have
children Diane Feinstein is 85 now she
is not the future of the Democratic
Party
Conrad Acacio Cortez is the future she
may be arrogant and dumb but at one
point she's absolutely right she is the
boss